there's nothing to worry about
everything's fine
we're gonna wash some games everything's
fine
nothing to worry about we're gonna play
some games we're gonna have some fun and
nothing bad will happen to anybody there
will be no consequences that happen
after you watch this video
everything is fine we are starting off
with what describes itself as a Silent
Hill remake am i playing I'm not playing
oh my god I am playing right now okay
now I should make it clear I have never
actually played a Silent Hill game maybe
I have have I you guys would know but
apparently but I don't think I've ever
actually oh I don't think I've ever
actually played a Silent Hill game let's
start I guess
well there we go okay okay we're good I
think we're good Oh
Cheryl
Jerell
okay Oh Cheryl sure Cheryl oh I'm here
okay Cheryl Cheryl Cheryl done did fall
out Oh what Oh weird oh okay oh well
this is bizarre I don't think the
original game was in first-person
perspective but I'll take it
yeah but honestly I have no idea if
there's going to be a faithful
recreation it feels kind of like it I
guess from what I've seen which are only
clips and screenshots of the game and I
think this is this is about like the
original original a lot of people quote
Silent Hill 2 is being like one of the
scarier ones but again I would not know
all right
Cheryl is that you Oh Cheryl Cheryl wait
stop Cheryl Cheryl Cheryl Cheryl Cheryl
damn Cheryl's quick yeah yeah I knew I
should have worked out more Cheryl get
your butt back here zero okay fine then
fine if that's how it's gonna be Cheryl
you go run off you gonna run off fine
yeah you're gonna survive in your own
and there's haunted town oh beware of
dog okay
all right Cheryl Cheryl you might want
to get back
Oh Cheryl there's a problem okay
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
okay oh wait a minute that's that ah is
this what the game was like just this is
this is spooky as hell what's happening
we do it with it
I don't need a little bit oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what are you
that's hell
that's it oh that's it okay well again I
I don't know how close this is to the
original I have no idea so I yeah I was
interested demo everything is always
always temporary okay anyway moving on
okay this game is called the mm I don't
know what the mm to the memorial mighty
Institute to the monster and I do
believe that we got to go in to Pluto to
get water who leaves salmon out
perfectly pristine grilled salmon just
left out to rot okay inventory do I have
an inventory I do oh oh
dumbass here's a hint to get out of here
if you lost your key card you're the
light of my life too bad I don't know
how to turn you on
oh it's a good thing mm I found us
morning Fred it's me Fred as usual I'm
sure you don't remember how you got or
here or why you're here it's okay you
wrote this to yourself as a reminder you
work here the MMI takes care of us
all you have to do is make the rounds
and don't touch anything leave this on
the desk so you can read it each morning
you put it in your inventory didn't you
I did all right how do I put it back I
owe conveniently I can't see myself
interesting okay so the clue is you're
the light of my life
I just don't know
thank you yeah red button in the cargo
room the one thing I seem to always
remember okay
mission saving the earth from olive you
who is all of you who who is all of you
where am I
are we on Pluto oh oh wow oh wow this
looks really fancy what what's going on
what is what is he what is even
happening what is this place
what is he mm I what's some mulberry
boob Institute I don't know what you're
about okay whatever I gotta go start up
a back-up generator or something oh yeah
this looks like way beyond my paygrade
in terms of complex electrical systems
so could I do it
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
what's happening you you need to explain
this to me what's happening
Oh
hi hello
wait is that me I don't know hello what
is happening I'm so confused
okay I'm very hot I'm just gonna yeah
I'm just gonna pretend like that didn't
happen and I'm just gonna carry on my
way got a lot of things to do today busy
busy man is me I'm a busy man no key
card inventory oh yeah good question why
what did you do is this ectoplasm I hope
it's not
don't go in there in there you mean ah
yes
they're very helpful I'm sure this is
some kind of time loop tell me you whoa
oh well that's not good
okay is this this all of you I've been
told so much about what were you saying
[Music]
okay yeah that's fine saving the earth
from all of you I don't know
he drops everything someone has the key
card Oh
all of you it can't be you you you who
who you who is you did you drop a cute
oh oh oh this better not be poop god I
really hope that's not poop on the walls
oh well don't mind if I do
I don't like a ticking clock Friday oh
hey all of you Oh what huh what's up
that's me a pebble oh great okay
apparently it's time to dine and go into
tomorrow
what is wait no no why did I come in
here yeah good question why did I come
in here I don't know because it seemed
like the thing I was supposed to do I'm
not oh there I go
this is the MMI warning
thank you some training wait wait wait
wait wait a minute
boy hey just because you work alone
doesn't mean you are alone wait a minute
wait you lie oh wait a minute wait a
minute wait my salmon okay it's still
there oh that's a lot of blood
everywhere
hey wait wait a minute wait a minute
wait wait what did that say the name was
four red five 12 six a key card
okay we'll have a good day you have a
good day to all of you whoever you are I
don't understand what the objective here
is are you doing Fred
okay all right Sheeran Fred what's
happening what's going on this is absurd
all right whatever I'm just gonna it's
gotta go through my suit this is
different I killed them all
[Music]
apparently I killed them all oh wait
maybe maybe I shouldn't oh you know what
whatever whatevs okay you got it all of
you
I all love you all of you oh oh oh
saving the earth from all of you I I'm a
changed man my life has been flipped
turned upside down that's insanity
okay that's great my head hurts but it's
great I think I'm not really well done
like it looks great too like good god if
this is for a game Jim really well done
stuff all right moving on
so this game is called unaware I don't
hear anything right now
actually I do I'm gonna add in music so
this game is called unaware I don't know
what I'm unaware of but I know that
it'll probably make me aware by jumping
in my face where am I
how did I end up here strange I can't
seem to remember anything
I'm so unaware of my circumstances
respond to view your inventory oh I owe
an inventory system interesting I should
light up the candle before I take it oh
I see I like that I like that light my
candle
I like that great now I can see better
oh look you found will you be your own
journal throughout the game press J to
look at the journal Oh boots you
collected an item which can be equipped
oh I put on boots this is rad it's
actually more than just a surface level
spooky game I'm sorry that I'm so
flabbergasted by this but I like it I
should see if there's anyone here I need
to know where I am and how I got here I
haven't got a clue amnesia amnesia I
woke up in this big house but I don't
know where I am
furthermore I don't remember anything
not even my own name
alright well interesting I'm not gonna
say it now I'm gonna jot your journal
there was a ghost girl across room
nothing about that you're not gonna
gonna do nothing take this key though
whatever this was Oh Oh a puzzle okay
alright so there's some kind of a puzzle
here knows a clock seems to be out of
order okay given that I don't exactly
know what time it is
[Music]
what happened what did I miss
did something happen or is that just
normal Oh lock new puzzles okay
well interesting uh alright so I need to
get solve the puzzle okay what does this
say there is a star to the right of a
square alright well that helps a little
bit I guess
alright so I gotta solve the puzzle I
like this ambition there's so many games
that I play these days that are just
like walk down this hallway and like it
actually trying something she looked for
missing pieces okay so there's there's a
couple of this like the puzzle room I
gotta get stuff and come back to the
puzzle room oh come on now you think you
can fool me with that I know what's
going on here oh yeah
the King had it all planned first he
placed the two the marks on his map and
then the king ordered a party of four
nights with long Lance's and twelve
soldiers with short swords to go on an
adventure outside the Forbidden Kingdom
the king was praying to the party
successfully would return back to the
kingdom with the treasure he was looking
for well I'm sorry it was but was
literally any of that that you just did
okay whatever okay so there's quite a
few puzzles here Oh thought that's my
air conditioner I thought yeah uh Italy
got spooked by that I don't know why
okay newspaper just no newspapers that
may be like as firewood or something
maybe okay oh-hoo it's a lot going on
here a lot to take in
they're really they're really throwing
the ringer in it I kind of like it I
like it a lot
I like it a great deal oh yeah okay yeah
just shove every bit of food in my gob
you guys mind I don't have what I need
to let up the stove yet I mean I've got
a newspaper she'll wait till the stove
is loaded all right whatever you say man
whatever you say god there's a lot to do
I don't I I don't know why I'm so
tickled that that like wrong key
AHA I don't know I'm so tickled that
there's actually more to this game but
it's such it's just a rare thing to see
when you're playing like I was flapping
my gums I didn't even realize I was
going well ain't a minute what was that
what was happening wait I am unaware of
a situation here
is there something down there oh my god
please no I don't want it I'm - ah yeah
I'm too handsome to die you can't kill
me think you can kill a face that's
beautiful I don't think so just
desperate to try something you know how
it is okay a circle is to the left of
the red figure a red figure is left of a
green figure do so many puzzles my brain
okay you can't do that game you can't do
that
oh my god you cannot you can't just do
that you think that you can just do that
oh I have legs I didn't even know I had
legs you think you can just stop the
music close that just gonna close it and
rethink my life for quickly okay I've
rethought it regret everything I've ever
done hello hi I'm back it's me again
your boy mark EMU not ready to hit why
not
okay I got to get some things before I
go outside apparently I could ignite
this you know why not I say why not a
lot and I'm saying why not right now
okay what is this thing did I get I
don't think I got us don't worry for
that so I'm gonna come back it might be
a puzzle I could solve at face value but
I'm just gonna you know it's gonna try
to do some other stuff I am going to do
that yes I will us looking more homey
already
oh wait I'm just I'm sorry hi wait no
wait hi
what hi are you should I talk to you oh
hello mister my name is Elizabeth oh hi
what is your name what are you doing in
my house you know eat your food stealing
your clothes I don't know I don't even
know where I am I don't recognize this
house James can you tell me can you tell
me maybe but you have to help me first
oh good favors to you that makes sense
stranger what do you need help with I
can't find my violin my mom has put it
away because she is upset now I want to
play it again well if your mom put it
away I can't override your mother as I
am a stranger I'll be very happy if you
can retrieve it for me
I'll try finding your violin all right
this is perfectly normal
normal normal normal everything that's
happening here uh what just happened
behind me little kid you got it you have
to stop you have to stop you have to
stop you are legally obligated to stop
oh hi what did I just get uh oh yeah I
know what this means this clearly means
what hi kid you have to stop you have
gotta stop I am not afraid to slap a
child you have gotta stop
maybe yeah the book fits in this flow
let's try that okay is it the correct
one I don't know okay what about this
other book ooh okay
did that do it you have to stop you must
okay let's try the other way around and
not the right book oh hey there's a
piece okay kid you I swear to God stop
running at me I will kick you I'm gonna
close this door because I don't like you
okay what do we have here I don't know
what I just got another candle yes
please because I'm about to run out
okay lock do I have a key for that yes
no I don't barely not okay that's fine
okay I think I got a piece for this Oh
Oh it's part of another puzzle ah
there's a lot of puzzles here guys turns
out there's a lot of puzzles can't
believe those books therefore now
there's got to be more downstairs that
I've missed Oh what what if I just get
what is this chef's hat oh it's a coat
it did not look like a coat but I got a
coat so that's good I've eaten their
food oh wait no I needed to cook the
food fire before food okay wood wood
wood I need to get wood where am I gonna
get wood
Oh wood Oh there's wood right by the
stove that is really convenient
I do realize now that that is very
convenient I'm gonna pop this should
heat up the pan well
I'm sorry excuse me excuse me
Oh oh yeah okay yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
I'm hungry this is a hungry man I like
it medium rare
all right apparently I like it well-done
pop that bad boy in my mouth give me
give me give me give me another one you
know I love me my steak I think all
right eat it till I can't eat no more
fire there whispers coming from the base
that I'm sorry if you could stop talking
just period flat out just hard stop on
the talking would greatly appreciate it
nom-nom-nom all your food is mine my
mine
oh god oh god oh oh okay I thought all
right sure yeah that god you're even
worse I don't know okay clock um
minute minute minute minute minute
minute minute minute I don't know what
time it is it was one of my was oh the
books the books the book ebooks
I forgot that I can actually read these
leaf will fall from the big tree
guidance for you to see huh 4:12 okay so
four o'clock maybe is that maybe that's
what it's about maybe that's not related
to chess at all maybe that's more for
right so this should be correct
God kid go away this is the number of
limbs oh okay it was the number of limbs
okay all right that makes sense um a
yellow figures to the left of the green
figure I don't know where these figures
are but I've got enough to solve the
puzzle upstairs some to go I'm gonna go
figure that one out because I've got
what I need apparently Gilles stay away
from me kid
you stay no don't lock me in here with
her I walked in there with her okay
there we go good okay so the urinal no
the the note star to the right of the
square okay stir I think this is all
relating to the same thing yellow
figures to the left of the green figure
stars to the right of the square
interesting interesting circle is to the
left of the red figure and the red
figures to the left of the green figure
okay circle to the left of red
whatever's red so the circle cannot be
green is what it's saying here okay I
think okay let's let's let's look at
this so the circle cannot be green
circles left to the right so this must
be red right hey I did it I got it oh
boy do I get a violin yay I did it I
used my brain I used my big brain okay
so I've got another piece there there's
only one more piece that I need hey kid
okay hey kid yeah now you have you found
my violin I sure did that's a book here
you go reading his power
you found it thank you yeah who's in
locked cabinet oh thanks okay I got
alright maybe she knows about the area
is she alone in this okay what is this
location Oh
ran worth England great where are your
parents
my dad is rarely here it's only my mom
and Missy who are you who's Missy Do You
Know Who I am I don't know who you are
but you seem nice you should not trust
strangers in your house
it doesn't matter kid but also I have a
funny feeling that this house is a
little more
you do not do that to me every end has a
beginning and maybe it's a clue for
something every end is the beginning I
don't know are you talking about my end
everything has an end okay so I don't
know what you want me to do what do I do
what am i doing oh you're kidding I had
to do Oh why are you kidding me
Oh Oh
okay so what was confusing about that Oh
what was confusing about that is I had
to do the clock after I put the books in
not before so you could see I'd be a
little bit confess 'old about that also
why is it so goddamn cold blink
why are you cold I'm so cold
please is cold okay there we go that's
good all right let's see what this is
about Oh what did I just get what Oh a
hammer I can smash the chess board I can
break it up Oh could this be the
entrance to the Attic nah nah man what
are you talking about nah what how do i
I did nothing
did a whole lot of nothing oh there dick
dentally and nothing oh hi I'll read
this scroll sure a.m. don't map it's a
map it's it's a map it's a map all right
holy hell okay it's uh it's a map
interesante I'm glad I got that now I
can go venture off into the woods and
die apparently maybe that's enough that
I need
well what did I just get is this
grandma's ashes it's a lamp oh okay
that's better
it's a lamp I thought it would be
something else but it's a lamp okay
what's with these books on the ground
what happened who who caused all this
devastation and why okay so I haven't
done the chest one yet but frankly I
feel like I'm missing some key
information about that I'm thinking that
something about that's a little
problematic okay I'm gonna go now
I think anyway oh I'm not ready to head
outside okay I'm very confused
uh I know not Dolf where I am if this is
what I'm supposed to do I'm gonna be
real pissed
oh that's all oh that's I just hadn't
reset the board every end has a
beginning meaning that makes that makes
sense okay
all right I was like do I need to put
them both into checkmate no no ah there
we go okay what have I got here
I think I'm ready to head us I think I'm
ready
diary oh no wait please this what I just
got
Darwin was still busy with his fishing
because of what he has was not much
around the house during the dead it's
been two hours practicing piano today as
I was playing Elizabeth's interrupted me
until was shown a new friend she's very
excited in her voice I wish she would
take a violin lessons more seriously at
over Elizabeth talking to herself
conversation playing with the doll ah
good Missy
Oh Missy you're really worried about
Elizabeth can't make her play along it
with me anymore nice practice can't talk
any sense into her more strange with
love it
talked about a man wandering around the
house hold the phone Elizabeth mentioned
that she is helping this man and asked
me if I know him I have never heard
about this man she is constantly talking
about if Elizabeth seeing things I do
where is she just using her imagination
making the characters up I stuck to
Darwin about this he's rarely I see I
see I see the one who is unaware is not
me
it's everybody else is uh what about the
door in the basement oh come on what
about the door in the basement fine fine
fine I was enjoying myself you had some
spooky atmosphere there goddamnit I was
in whatever it's fine okay sure so that
was three scary games that last one was
a long one but it still counts in three
scary games thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
as always see you in the next video
[Music]